this this box right here
is so like virgin Because by the time
this gets finished with them they never
get to the Box
one-on-one situation
all right Annette yes and that uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally I'm from Elizabeth New Jersey
on the East Coast tell me about your
family
um I'm the youngest of 10 children my
family's um
component maybe three components that's
the alcoholics the drug addicts and the
church folks that's the three components
that's how we made up
um my mother was a product of an
interracial relationship back in the
South when it wasn't popular
matter of fact it was taboo and when she
was born
um this the mother felt that she was
doing her justice
Association and telling them if they
wanted that [ __ ] they better come get
it before she died so my mother grew up
with her grandparents who was her her
father's
mother and father
and she was drinking at a very early age
I think she was drinking when she was
two she was dipping snuff
and as they were getting older
they had to hurry up and marry her off
because they were dying so she got mad
when she was 13 to a pretty much grown
man
she never knew her mother and that's all
we ever heard all the time as far back
as I can remember she would say I never
knew what it was like to have a mother
she never knew her mother she never knew
if she had sisters or brothers because
she came out black and they were white
so it wasn't happening
and I don't know why we didn't think and
I mean I have brothers and sisters older
than myself why didn't anyone seem to
look up her last name and try to you
know give her some closure on it I
didn't think about it until
um later on in life but I started it but
it just didn't complete it because I was
never home I wasn't I was always on the
move
well I can tell you this from
but I've been told when I was born my
mother went into a coma I was told that
I didn't mean my mother until I was two
years old my oldest sister
her nickname was happy
she um pretty much took care of me all
my sisters was raped by my oldest
brother the firstborn
my mother had eight kids down South by
her husband when she was young and she
said he used to stab her in his stomach
when she was pregnant and they had this
um
filled where they grew their own food
and all week long they would work
together but on the weekends they take
off and go on their separate directions
and leave the kids there so she had
eight kids down south
now my oldest brother Junior raped all
of my sisters before me
and the story went like um
he was big he was a bully so he made my
other brothers guard the door while he
raped one of my sisters and they said
hey I've heard some of my brothers told
me like when I was growing that they
heard it but it was nothing they can do
because they were scared you know and so
one of them supposedly had gotten
pregnant but lost the baby and then for
whatever reasons my mother moved from
down south to Jersey
where she met my father and my father
was married and he had 10 kids and so he
worked for Ford and um
the first child she had by him
I was a boy was my brother pinky who
passed he's older than I am but he was a
baby boy
and then when I came along
I heard somehow she made sure that the
wife found out
and that caused problems because
um it was something I had some kind of
um litigation they were having the
father wanted to take me and my brother
away from her but the judge wouldn't let
you know that happened wouldn't let us
leave my mother but um
uh I kind of wonder what it would have
been like if that had my life might have
been different but anyway in the
meantime
okay now here I am right and
my sister happy is taking care of me
I had no memory of my childhood from the
age of 13 down because it was so hellish
I was being
raped and molested so much that I
blocked the whole thing out as told by
my psychologists psychiatrists and
psychoanalysts
and um
but I started getting memories they were
so hellish that I thought I was losing
my mind I didn't think that there was
any way possible these things could have
been happening to me so
I asked a family friend one time I had
this dream and I remembered the mattress
I remember being in a basement I
remember it was a little light bulb that
hung by a string I remember the the
brick that was in the walls because the
cement was sloppy you know point out and
I remember looking up and seeing my
sister happy come in the basement and I
was so happy to see how I jumped up and
ran and what she did she just turned me
around and she walked she wiped the
blood and the feces that was running
from my behind down my legs
and she cleaned me up and turned me back
around and sent me right back to my
brother so he can finish doing with me
what he wanted to do and this went on
for a long time and that was just one
memory I had another memory I'm in the
basement again
and I'm on this table a little bit
higher than that one and I'm on my back
and as far as I can see it was so many
boys
yeah I think I just detached because
when the memories came back they were so
horrific I remember my hands was
bleeding for me like
I guess
um resistance you know how much painful
it might have been
and it would be bleeding and when I
asked this family friend about it I said
did something happen to me her name was
Christine I said Christine if something
happened to me when I was little and so
she said happened to you like what I
said did somebody do something to me you
know and I gave her that look and she
said you need to ask your mama
so that told me she knew something
happened to me so when I asked my mother
my mother said no did nothing happen to
me and I was like Mama you sure she said
it doesn't happen to you so I asked my
sisters and this is when the truth
started coming out anyway it took a long
time
um before I had any memories of my
childhood
and um to say that I can speak about a
feeling like this now is because it
doesn't bother me you know I mean some
of them was I still give them some time
to time new ones
and it's only when I it seems like when
I'm totally comfortable and relaxed that
their surface and they're always worse
than the previous ones
and how I ever survived my childhood I
really don't know I guess it was just by
the grace of God that I said father and
I'm glad we got all that hell out of the
way then so that I can make my own help
for myself which I do very good
so um moving right along I got married
um my first husband
his name was Furman Eugene Porter he's
about seven feet tall he would have to
bend down to come through a door that
was almost about his height almost he
was tall he used to be a pro basketball
player so I hear I don't know if it
ain't truth to that I know he spoke
about six different languages he taught
himself
this is how Annette started doing drugs
because then that was anti-drug as we
were coming up because I had a brother
Whitney who went into the army and he
came I don't know what happened to him
but I noticed that you know he was
shooting dope head and he was hanging
out of his arms he used to torment me
and my brother and tell her we got in
there never do drugs you need to be
sitting in the chair he said you but I
never did your decision but I never
never do drugs so he was scared right so
here comes my first husband right
and I did pretty good for myself you
know I had a daughter and I just noticed
things were missing around the apartment
so I was saying to my sister-in-law and
I don't understand what's going on I
said I ain't got no money nowhere around
the house things are just coming up
missing and I I can't figure it out she
said that's because ken2 is doing
Freebase and I said well what's the
Freebase do you know what Freebase was
lo and behold when I confronted him
he decides
he's going to you know do the drug of
the house he's not it's my fault of
course because I wouldn't let him do it
in the house and I would make such a
bitching sound about it that he had to
go out and and be with other women to do
this throughout it was all my fault so
to fix this he was going to make me do
the drug right that's how these things
came out because I said no pop
my brother said learn how to duck so I
took that to heart and then I got six
stitches here of the eye I got a
fractured ribs and then my girlfriend
was telling me she said and that's just
just just do the damn thing you know you
don't have to do it alone I'll do it
with you this is my friend she never did
drugs and she went through this with me
she did it with me because she didn't
want me to do it by myself when I was
forever grateful to her
so here we go and then when it got to
the point to where
I didn't know how to quit I said how do
I stop he said
and walk right out of my life like
mission accomplished that's all I wanted
to do was [ __ ] you up
but anyway in spite of that I ended up
I ended up going into construction I
worked for all the Fortune 500 companies
and
um then I started I was a stripper I was
a prostitute I was a model these things
kind of came like back to back behind
each other
and then
when I found out I can only go so high
in the Fortune 500 company
I switched it over to construction
because you can make a lot of money in
construction and so there I go I met
this guy I don't know if I should say
their name because yeah
so we better leave that alone I went
there for a year I learned to trade and
then I had my own
business I had a beautiful life with
them
um had a gorgeous house
had a
condo in Fort Lee
had a condo in Leonia
had two pieces of property and Ringwood
house
made housekeeper
I mean my children went to school with
um Stephen Morrison Morris kids which
was Stevie Wonder You know and they had
a beautiful life it wasn't like they
just went to school and came home to an
empty house they went to school they had
piano lessons they had
um vocal lessons they had martial arts
because they had a Life Style
and the thing that I learned about being
rich and being poor is that you're
saying
rich people do the same thing someone
that poor people do when there's no one
home they let the kids come home what
they call latchkey kids they come home
ain't nobody there sometimes they don't
even have a man or a housekeeper there
and they come in a housing nobody calls
cyphus on them Child Protective Services
because they're in a different bracket
so they're protected and I noticed that
and I noticed a lot of things that was
just discriminating when I was going to
school I used to wonder about
the people that was in office like do
they know that in this neighborhood
somebody dies every weekend
good evening can do they know that we
got these
books that pages are missing out of them
and they raggedy and they're dirty and
they're all dude politicians even care
about all this stuff that this American
dream is about and that got me into
politics for a little bit Yeah I dabbled
in that for a minute but it just seemed
to me that it was something really
really wrong
but the way that I was coming up and I
noticed that
when I would go to my friend's house
things are just different like it was
clean for one my mom used to drink and
she used to have a whole lot of male
guys come over and she used to dip Snips
over split Tunes all around and I used
to have to jump out the windows because
some of these men wanted to get me
so my brother pinky taught me how to
jump out the window so I'd be all right
and um my mom when she got drunk she
used to get butt naked it was no secret
what went on in her bedroom she left the
door open we could see everything
and um she would walk down the street
butt naked you know sometimes I'll be
coming in from one of my friend's house
downtown and my friend Cherise would say
to your mom and naked walking down the
street I said you help me get it sure
they will help me get my mother bringing
the house you know and
she was a piece of work she was a legend
in her own and you know an Elizabeth
everybody knew it from the police
officers to every
um nursing doctor in the hospital they
know who she was they called the mama
Felton she got drunk one time she loved
to drive when she was drunk she got
drunk
she hit the fire hydrant she hit the
street light and then she rolled up
between the sliding door she crafted
nose and got out the car and said that
she needed help
because she did some things in her days
she would take us fishing with her to
these
places so
far away and we had to go down these
steep hills and watch out watch out for
that the cow manure and snake holes and
all this kind of stuff to get to this
edge of the bank
and my mother would stay there from
before the sun came up
to after the summer down everybody's
ready to go she still got her pole in
the water
she's fishing when we would come back we
had to walk like it seemed like a
million miles just to the car but I
understand as an adult why she did that
she did it because she probably didn't
have any money
to feed a kid so she took us fishing you
know to make sure that we had something
to eat
but my mother was drunk the whole house
was drunk but when my mother was sober
she would clean the house so good you
would probably have to wear shades to
walk through it
but she
she just um
I think she had a horrible life
you know and a lot of things she just
didn't talk about she's always proud of
the one thing she never know who her
mother was
let me tell you about my second husband
my second husband believe it or not when
I was with this guy
who we know who was where he was from
um he had this woman he paid her like
five or five thousand dollars for a
reading right
this woman told me she said I was going
to meet my husband in a warm climate
she said I was going to have two sons
and at the time being on the East Coast
I never wanted to come to California I
saw people were crazy to live in
California because they know it's going
to be an earthquake why would you want
to live someplace where there's going to
be an earthquake and you're going to go
up under
that was never a part of my plan however
the state would have it
like she said I came into a warm climate
I met my husband who died just last year
in October from Fentanyl
and I had two sons by him and you know
some people
can be very accurate in this thing I
think that she was more than just a
psychic I think I think she was just
undercover prophet and didn't know it
you know to be so accurate
and the reason he took me to her because
he wanted to know if we were going to be
together even though we got the blessing
to get married and all that kind of
stuff just wasn't funny because
at first I really cared about this man
but then he became so controlling that
it just
just edged any films that I had you know
out the pictures and he told me to marry
him anyway just for convenience I said
no I said I kind of got married the
first time it was quote unquote
convenience because I was going to get
some things out of it but it wasn't
worth it I said if you marry somebody
you should marry someone who's who's
going to love you go to the curb and
back with you you know
I said not because you got money or
because of the things you can get them
but because of who you are inside so if
anything should happen your looks are
going to fade mine says
but Luke's will say your body's going to
get older
and then if the person only like my
husband told me the second one said he
already married me for my body
yes that's what he did he reminded me
for my body not because of who I was I
was inside just for the image
and so I started letting myself go after
that pretty much because
you know when you think someone when you
when you when love is a wonderful thing
and for someone to just come in and
abuse that and just shatter everything
every
every
emotion every
I guess feeling any label you can put on
it this this shatters the whole thing I
mean I was so I mean it's one thing to
get along let me say my first broken
heart I didn't even know what it was I
just you know
um equated it with pain what do you do
with pain you take aspirin right
I thought if I take a ass when I get rid
of this heart feeling right it doesn't
work we went past our broken heart we
went to a broken Spirit we went past the
broken spirit this man had mine he I
mean I was shattered my spirit was
shattered like a billion pieces I mean
it's like Humpty Dumpty fell off the
wall so many pieces they couldn't put it
back together that's how it was for me I
mean I I let so much of myself go
to be what he wanted me to be you know I
was so meshed into this man that when he
rejected me my God it was just like um
Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde having to ripped
himself apart it was so hard for me to
do but when I did it I was so happy I
was so glad when I no longer loved him
because then I was able to get myself
back it took a long time and I'm still
working right through this day
so that's how much that I've seen as
long as I kept everybody outside of my
little circle I was fine but when you
let someone in your heart
that's when they can do damage because
when they get that hard they can do a
whole lot of damage here and up here my
head and my heart never agreed my heart
is full of love
but my head is always
checking this personal but they're doing
and what they're saying because of what
they're doing doesn't add up to what
they're saying my head's going to let me
know my heart's got to feel bad about it
because we could have done so much here
and I thought
that anyone if you poured so much love
into them that they can change
I was wrong again
some people are so evil some people are
so selfish they will take everything you
got when you don't have anything else to
give them get out
they don't care they're just in it for
what they can get and some people are so
evil
talking about evil
love has nothing to do with they will
say whatever they think you want to hear
they will be ever but you they think you
want them to be to get in to get you and
a lot of people down here it's just like
that they scam you it's like they got
this way of just scanning you and
whatever which way they find there's a
little opening
gotcha
they get in get what they want to know
as much as they can get and then they're
out and it sounds so believable
but you've got some magnificent con
artists down here
talking about different doubles on
different levels city of Los Angeles
City of Angels
gotta be kind of demon down here and
they are at work
and so that's my story anything else
agenda down here how'd I end up down
here it was because
I was on my way to Vegas it was me and
bear it was the only time that I was
stripping I would go to Vegas because
they would have these final conventions
and porno stars don't like going out
with porno chicks they like going out
with regular women and it was a great
deal for me you know they start out 500
on the table back then you know and it
just the longer you said the more money
you made so it was coming from this
final convention office on a way to one
I know I think it was going out there
and the car broke down because I asked
him to show me
um
I wanted to see L.A and I asked him to
show it to me and as he was coming on
the bridge I saw all these 12
skyscrapers and said oh wait I said I
think I like it and um we got here the
car broke down and
for some reason he started showing me
skip over was to sing to sing and we
came down here
and then we got into an argument and
then I went my way and he went his way
but she was still stuck with the car but
I ended up going into this program I was
asking where could I stay for the night
and they told me to just go to Safe
Harbor
I went over there and end up doing a
program you know that's how I met my
husband but that's how I ended up in LA
just like uh we were using the whole
time
was I using when I came here probably
I've been using ever since that day
happened when I first picked it up and
you know
on and off for years
I don't know if he is correct
well it was called Freebase in and then
it went to I guess cocaine it didn't
want to crack and now so much crap in
the crack you know what the hell again
and a lot of people have been dying from
fentanyl you know so yeah
how are you supporting yourself now
am I supporting myself
of course darling I'm supporting myself
dressed like that
no no this is just how a dress is the
only way I've ever known how to dress
unless I was going to church now
but yeah this is pretty much our address
how do you make money how do I get money
you see the ones that I'm with I spend
their money they spend money on me
and we're just best friends we're really
friends because a lot of times you know
what I have this
gift I'm so talented to that
and I got the title when I was in New
York it's called a Dick's sport
naturally excellent in sucking dick just
a pro at it people who couldn't get an
erection from head
listening to me baby I got him I'm just
good at it I don't nothing that I
practice at and have to work at it just
natural
account that I have what can I say I
have other talents sure I could sing but
that one just seems to work and a lot of
guys I'm gonna I want to get I want to
hit this this box right here
is so like virgin Because by the time
this gets finished with them they never
get to the Box
one-on-one situation
you have any regrets in your life
yeah
nope I don't have any regrets since I
really think as it was if anything was
to change it would change everything
right
I wouldn't change anything
because I got a hard ass head like some
people they learned a lesson the first
time not me some lessons I got to go
through again and again and again and
again until I get it but then when I get
it I got it you know you don't have to
worry about that lesson but life has a
funny way of doing things you can know
something right
and then Elevate to another level and
learn the same thing just in a different
way you know it's just like they say if
you keep throwing up shots at the basket
hoop after a while you know you become
good at making the shot well now you're
good at making the shot but the same
principles for that you can't apply it
to something else and you'll let
everything comes closer and you'll get
right back to where you started from
again same thing same but a whole
different meaning
how old are you now I'm 62. you're 62.
62. you're great for 62. well thank you
I could look better what I want to do I
want to
um
start bodybuilding I want to get myself
back together you know I want to put all
the energy that I funneled out on so
many people
and put it back into myself
and I would like to get me
not imagine but in the state and have
all my children Up Under One Roof up
under different wings
and I would like everything that I'm
doing for me and mine I would like to do
for the rest of the world
I want people to be happy
as possible and the ones that are really
like socially passages you know just put
all them people on one side of the
Equator and all the other people on the
other side I think that makes our job a
lot easier
and that's just me what's your biggest
fear
my biggest I don't think I
mean my one of my biggest fears is after
I leave this life and I'm going home
my biggest fear is for a christ to say
that he never knew me
that would be my biggest fear
because I acknowledge Him in all the
things that I do I give him thanks for
everything and I know that everything
happens the way exactly the way it's
supposed to happen in order for you to
become who he predestined you to be for
the foundations of the world
so to go through this life and get to
the end of it and as you're entering
home for him to say that he don't know
you
man you ain't got no more life
that's it
Life as we know it it's over and in life
beyond
that's my biggest fear
I mean that would you what would you say
is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life love
love because love is so powerful you see
The Exorcist right and you see how scary
the demons and everything look
you know what overcomes that
love overcomes evil
evil doesn't overcome evil love
overcomes evil and all that you know
we've got people
well the most horrific Evils are
overcome by love
so when you think about love that's a
very powerful instrument to overcome
that kind of evil
yes I think that's the most important
lesson that I've learned because love is
a beautiful thing I've seen alcoholics
stop drinking over love when somebody
loved them pour love into them I've seen
some drug addicts stop using even you
know smokers you know
love can do a multitude of things when
it's applied
the right way
and when it's also received
everybody can't receive a lot
oh yeah that's it all right Annette
thank you so much for sharing your story
oh anytime I got lots more to tell you
people have you back okay thanks